ci sono due modi per raccontare l'idea
dell'ora
questa e piazza vittorio 1 e farla
suonare e il risultato li potrei anche
garantirlo l'altra è che io vi racconti
com'è andata a finire è il risultato qui
non lo garantisco completamente 13 anni
fa mi sono trasferito con mia moglie a
piazza vittorio e ci piaceva il
quartiere anche se un po degradato però
era pieno pieno di vita
allora c'era ancora il mercato
all'aperto ed era un mercato storico
della città che negli anni era diventato
un mercato multietnico che gli era
frequentato da immigrati da residenti
storici la coppia di giovani da artisti
che compravano casa di perché costava
poco tra vestiti borse borseggiatori
insomma a me più che le metropoli
moderne e mi ricordava la roma imperiale
quel tipo di promiscuità che mi sembrava
allo stesso un momento moderna e antica
e per cui capivo anche perché sarà
quella quel senso di convivialità quella
normalità nei rapporti
insomma ero innamorato del posto e un
giorno di passeggiata con mia moglie
romantica gli ho detto amore mio mi
piacerebbe dedicare un orchestra questa
piazza
un'orchestra di immigrati l'idea mia
moglie piacque molto
piaceva anche a me piaceva a tutti
quelli a cui la raccontavo per cui in
pochissimo tempo attorno a questa idea
si è creato una massa di gente che formò
anche un'associazione culturale
all'associazione apollo 11 che voleva
salvare un cinema del dell'esquilino che
stava per diventare una sala bingo e
aveva anche intenzione di promuovere la
nascita di questa orchestra c'era anche
un documentarista il presidente
dell'associazione che mi disse voglio
fare un film di questa storia e gli
dissi mediatamente the city se lo stilo
guarda male che vada raccontiamo un
fallimento perché
ipotesi del fallimento era busto
probabile era un progetto difficilissimo
complicato impossibile quasi era il 2001
rive il la condizione degli immigrati in
italia era difficilissima c'era una
legge la bossi fini che c'è ancora e poi
e poi arriva all 11 settembre che
complica ancora di più le cose anche il
nostro entusiasmo post vani per cui non
ne parliamo più per un poco e anche la
piazza diventò più brutta perché nel
frattempo che quei mesi il mercato era
passato al al coperto e la piazza aveva
perso un po la sua anima e verrà quasi
tutto diventato negozi cinesi e c'era
uno stato di polizia carabinieri e
bandiere italiane scritte contro gli
stranieri e quindi era il progetto
diventava ancora più complicato però
vinta quella depressione dopo qualche
mese apple o 11 organizzato una
manifestazione davanti al cinema apollo
un concerto spettacolo con sceneggiatori
e registi musicisti che fu un successo
enorme vennero più di cinquemila persone
questo successo convinse il comune di
fermare i lavori per il vino
quindi era un primo successo e noi
eravamo contentissimi e due mesi dopo
addirittura era già nel 2002 il comune
di roma con l'assessore bornia che
saluto dovunque
si invita nel cinema a per un meeting
nel cinema apollo apre il cinema
all'associazione apollo 11 e per
discutere del destino che aveva quella
sala lo stesso giorno la stessa mattina
io però avevo dato appuntamento a un
musicista un trombettista e quando
arriva a casa e dico guarda omar
perdonami che dobbiamo andare presto si
nyman cinema bellissimo da era un teatro
negli anni venti in stile deco che
potrebbe diventare la casa e l'orchestra
e quindi aveva senza vieni con me porta
della tromba e quando arriviamo lì il
cinema stato completamente sventrato dai
lavori i tecnici che erano lì parlavano
di tantissimi soldi e tantissimo tempo
per ristrutturarlo per cui io dissi omar
bin e un attimo qua
disse oh ma la fai una cortesia questo
teatro dormirà per tanti anni gli
addetti che una canzone
beh
non avevamo una lira e non c'era non
avevamo posto per le prove insomma però
avevamo conosciuto omer da quel giorno
marche lo dico adesso tutto iniziò a
funzionare è perché ci chiamò romaeuropa
festival romaeuropa festival si chiama e
compra uno spettacolo per la chiusura
del festival del 2002 24 novembre del
eravamo praticamente il primavera
inoltrata era aprile maggio e compra uno
spettacolo dell'orchestra e noi capiamo
mentre la direttrice molik boot parlava
dell'orchestra che fosse convinta che
l'orchestra già era già suonasse già ma
in realtà quel momento l'orchestra
formata da cinque musicisti due italiani
un bassista e percussionista africano un
percussionista africano un suonatore di
oud tunisino è naturalmente omar lopez
valle qui andai da loro dis guardate
ragazzi ci abbiamo un contratto
abbiamo un contratto qui ci sono c'è una
data d'esordio che il 24 novembre
ci sono dei soldi per le prove ci
soddisfi per le prove e per l'esibizione
nel contratto c'è scritto 21 musicisti
è un ora e mezza di musica
adesso voi siete cinque le mancano 16
aiutatemi
visto che siete adesso non siete non una
vera e proprio che siete una band di
solito nelle band la prima cosa che si
fa per scaldare i muscoli è un blues
blues in rete core l attenzione mano è
evita le terze vago sul maggiore e
minore slide
maestro
si era sparsa la voce che pagavamo non
solo il concerto ma anche le prove per
cui i musicisti iniziano ad arrivare a
palate molti finti musicisti anche da
vedere ma anche delle perle assolute
purtroppo il budget che avevamo ci
consentiva solo cinque giorni di prove
che erano pochi erano pochissimi per cui
iniziai a frequentare i musicisti con e
portarli in studio da leandro e che che
con me collaborava agli arrangiamenti un
po alla volta uno alla volta piccoli
gruppi e raccontabile quella gioia quel
quella straordinaria magia che ci fu in
quei giorni però con i musicisti
arrivavano anche i problemi i problemi
legati all'immigrazione permessi di
soggiorni visti e quindi l'associazione
apollo 11 e il mio amore è mia moglie
vivevano continuamente nei uffici
migrazioni di una settimana prima
dell'esordio non sapevo realmente quale
sarebbe stata l'orchestra che poteva
salire sul palco però magicamente grazie
al grandissimo amore che c'era attorno a
questo progetto il giorno delle prove ci
eravamo tutti tutti e 21 e tutti con i
documenti a posto io il giorno primo
giovane le prove sono arrivato con 40
minuti di ritardo arriva in sala
trafelato e arrabbiatissimo
quindi entra gli feci la mia entrata
qualche voi conoscete questi quasi
urlando però quando entrai nella sala
l'orchestra già c'era era già tutta
piazzata c'è la gente che suonava certe
xvi xix che leggeva le parti ed era e
quel momento ho detto che amate fortuna
fare il musicista che che proprio che
che meraviglia i musicisti riescono a
fare amicizia come bambini senza bisogno
di nulla e io pensai allora io che devo
fà che devo portare questo incanto sul
palco e devo sfruttare questa
straordinaria anarchia
mettere delle regole e sperare che
questa vita che sale sul palco piacere
al pubblico questa storia non ha
fortunatamente un finale perché
l'orchestra c'è ancora
dopo 12 anni
e
è il 12 anni è diventata una vera o
chiesta perché c'è un sacco di
repertorio canzoni sono quattro anni che
siamo in tournée col flauto magico di
mozart
abbiamo esordito con la carmen di bizet
ma ci piace anche moltissimo far parlare
le persone nelle piazze e quindi
ringraziando iddio siamo ancora qua ma
il senso del nostro lavoro oggi ci è
dato da una cosa che succede a pochi
passi da piazza vittorio a tor
pignattara a tor pignattara
c'è un'orchestra giovanile nuova che
composta dai musicisti che tredici anni
fa quando è partita questa storia
avevano un anno oppure non erano in con
arci e oggi li abbiamo quanti abbiamo
anche qua anche in forma anzi diciamo di
band e sono simone jacopo eleonora
canta l'orchestra di piazza vittorio
insieme alla piccola stessa di tor
pignattara
dirige l'orchestra il maestro pino
pecorelli
per altro miliardo
aspettava che ne vado con loro ma domina
piazza vittorio con una penna di
garlasco
ma così voluto dare come lui siamo più
le gigli bianchi che hanno fatto mix più
all d
all